welcome to this video watching boy it's
paul and print it will be one time we're
still we have the Indonesian flag
they're destined SE portland anyway
Queens gambit declined their name no
right no okay like a three is not very
very aggressive really probably see six
and Bishop f5 okay Quincy to as possible
but I think i'm happy with this
yeah it should be a decent Queens gambit
declined exchange I got night g7 and
Bishop f5 coming up yeah that's a
classic maneuver and against this
opening trying to and trade the light
squared Bishop and it succeeded so night
over there and wonder if 94 is an option
here yeah night coming to see 5 I wonder
if b5 as something that I could try to
play it's a bit bit of a strange moment
for for this movement
okay 95 it's not the end of the world I
can even go to gate seven
okay that I didn't expect thought you
would play night c5 regardless ok and
here I thought I get in Knight b6 and
stuff Knight b6 94 oh I see coming no
with 95 ok 95 94 96 luque aid should be
ok really get a 3 back
hmm
maybe that wasn't so great Oh Katie
cheeks surprisingly that can only be
helpful for me I guess and why did why
did you play like that don't really
don't really get it look a one-set that
big deal
okay the dark squares really the problem
here Queen have six or something but I
don't don't quite get it let's go on da
file first hmm I wanted to go Queenie
seven which is not working of course
I'm what I would think
never see form I know now I can relax if
Wang is hmm I can never guess any move
here um so here and then he goes
specially 50
time warning yes 96 but I'm hoping that
he doesn't see it it's the only somewhat
interesting defense that I found I mean
found and I'm he does see it and I
scored 95 that ends every a little hope
yeah it's also good enough black resins
I spoiled a good position here i'm just
in fine shape but what did I spoil this
yeah I think I came that I have to avoid
to take I guess yeah the dental pics of
that position are probably just not in
my favor from a static point of view
this is this is ok to take because let's
say in a in a minor peas endgame I'm
okay here with this Bishop lot doing
much but the problem with Queen f6 is
too too big just too big and hear that
was a very optimistic move okay six
still seems to hold down here I'm losing
yeah like him it was a weird game I
didn't didn't predict most of his moves
there the way you played that is really
strange china allowing me to c4 and
stuff that that's really not necessary
at all but okay I have to avoid to take
I really have to avoid that move then he
gets Luca one though yeah probably queen
bee 7s then already questionable
something the engine wants to go f6 just
protect you five and continue from them
ok it's may be equal something about
this but yeah yeah it was a bad idea was
a bad idea to take ok well thanks for
watching